- I love mornings in the park.
The light through the trees,
the birds and the squirrels.
♪ It's Central Park ♪
♪ It's a haven,
it's a jewel ♪
[urinating]
- Sir, do not pee
on the statue!
- I love Hot Lips Turtlehead Day.
- More than graffiti removal week?
- Oh, I do love that.
- I should get going.
Who's my special boy?
- Me.
- Look at you. You are my special boy.
- Too bad you can't just
stick him back up there, huh?
- What?
- Nothing.
- I hate that park.
It's just a patch of dirt and weeds.
And we're gonna buy it.
We're gonna do
the biggest real estate deal
in the history of the world!
- Quick question over here, Betsy.
Are you wearing a dog?
- It's perfectly normal.
- I'm not gonna lie,
it's a little distracting.
- No it's not!
- Someone needs to
protect the park.
- It's impossible.
- Nothing's impossible.
- Did your voice
just get really weird?
♪ Central Park ♪
- How many times
did you text him?
- What would you say
is normal?
- Twice.
- Oh, no, no, no, no.
- Ugh, I'm dying.
- He's fine.
- Throw this. See if you can
get it into the park.
- Did you get it?
- Right where I wanted it.
♪ Where else can your
son and daughter ♪
♪ Splash in dirty
hotdog water ♪
- Give us a quick strut.
One for mama. Come on.
- Are we dancin'?
Yeah, we're dancin'.
- Is that dancing?
- We're gonna knock
these bozos' wieners off.
♪ Here at the meet point ♪
♪ A park that's so central ♪
♪ The name's not that clever ♪
♪ But screw it, whatever ♪
♪ It's central ♪
♪ In my ♪
♪ Heart ♪
- Good luck managing the park.
That's gonna go great for you.
- What's that supposed to mean?
- Nerd.